ça devrait se jouer le mettrais ma main
au feu par tous nous à l'aller c'est que
le coût de transport les jambes on vous
a parlé parce que c'est ça le coup le
plus important qu'on ait à subir à
région c'est le coût de transport et le
préfet avait totalement raison
on ne les transports qui est qui et qui
coûte quand même chiant à la real dès
qu'on a c'est la distance via le prince
pont qui s'ajoutent sur les factures de
tout le monde soit ceux certains vivent
nus en mégane i une des six régions de
la côte-nord un immense territoire mais
faiblement peuplées 6500 personnes
derrière ses paysages à couper le
souffle une réalité moins reluisante
faire son épicerie coûte cher
on est loin de l'ensemble du québec on
est quand même un 13 14 heures de route
de montréal thunder de québec
on sait combien plus cher les résidents
doivent payer ici la dernière étude de
deux mille ans nous devait pour sa plus
cher
donc ça a pas diminué au contraire
peut-être que ça s'est accentué un peu
presqu'au bout de la route 138
un peu plus de mille personnes vivent à
natashquan et dans la communauté innu de
nutte à quoi ça va bien louise
caillouette est propriétaire avec son
conjoint de la seule épicerie dans un
rayon de 150 km
si on regarde ça de l'extérieur on va
dire à voix basse et la seule épicerie
fait qu'il n'y a pas de compétition fait
qu'ils peuvent nous vendre à n'importe
quel prix pour vous offrir n'importe
quoi on marche pas une mince ça marche
comment brainois en état puis avec son
bolide
puis le des prix nous comme si acheter
des fruits légumes pains hocine même
prix que n'importe où dans province
c'est sûr que les choses sont un peu
plus dispendieuse par rapport au coût de
transport qui sont élevées qui joue dans
en quarante et cinquante mille dollars
par année qu'on doit être cheveux et
parce que les petites routes à bientôt
jusqu'à nous vous faites quoi dans ce
temps là on est obligé de la jolie nous
prîmes pour absorber ces frais l'eau la
plupart des aliments vendus ici
proviennent des entrepôts sobey's située
à terrebonne et québec
l'épicerie doit aussi faire affaire avec
des distributeurs indépendants pour
certains autres produits comme la viande
qui se vend seulement surgelés
les gens qui veulent avoir de la viande
par exemple du boeuf haché pour moins de
2 libre 800 grammes ces 15 dollars au
même moment les consommateurs dans les
grands centres payer 10 $ 50 de ma
viande rouge du bleu lavande charles de
porc de boeuf neupro choix puisqu'on ne
les frais de transport etc seront
exemptés bon morello comme le pain et
l'eau règles de pain et nous ça me coûte
sur les quinze pièces plus la surcharge
carburant
ça veut dire ça me revient à peu près
entre 40 et 50 cents par part pour le
brésil qui est ou d'autres aliments
comme ça vous n'avez pas le choix de
vendre plus cher qu'ailleurs et le lait
le lait le que c'est le plus onéreux
parce que lui ne fera pas lien il me le
faut ou pour résultat le lait coûte 16 %
plus cher qu presque partout au québec
les résidants n'ont d'autre choix que de
payer ce prix
encore faut-il que leur nez soit livré
la réalité d'un contenant ces qui
atteindront alors si la vôtre coupe ce
qui est une réalité c'est une réalité
l'hiver il peut y avoir un blizzard
l'appui il ya une journée où personne
semble assez comme ça
alors oui à des enjeux assurément
d'approvisionnement
les livraisons dans cette région arrive
aussi par bateau mais une seule
compagnie offre ses services
on est transport maritime qui dessert la
mégane et qui est 55 % du temps or cet
éloignement a aussi des impacts sur le
prix et la fraîcheur des aliments anti
que si lorsque sa rente tarder bateau
puis quel bateau saute le voyage plus
que les fruits de sens qu'à blanc-sablon
puis reviennent du vatican city le
programme figurent des fruits des
légumes frais sont passés date depuis
dix jours de jeu quand ils les reçoivent
plusieurs villages sont ravitaillées
uniquement par avion ou par train on a
reçu certaines marchandises
quand vous voyez j'imagine que les prix
d'augmenter où il donnait de transport
pour ces gens alors parce que l'on doit
prendre le train pour longtemps
devant tous ces obstacles
on est en droit de se demander si cette
population vit en toute sécurité
alimentaire tels que définis par le
gouvernement du québec est ce qu'on peut
dire que ici dans la région chacun peut
se procurer en tout temps une quantité
suffisante d'aliments sains et nutritifs
pour mener une vie saine et active y
assurer à ses enfants une croissance et
un développement adéquat de réponse est
donc oui à 25 pour saab et gel c'est sûr
que ne peuvent pas atteindre ces
standards l'eau on est tous deux régions
à typer donc on vit avec soyez de
résilience
mais c'est certain que on peut pas dire
que partout on peut se procurer des
fruits frais en abondance
on parle même de problèmes de santé
publique ou sur ce plan autochtones et
non autochtones sont égaux quand je
pense aux personnes par exemple mais
johan beetz sont à 65 km de saint pierre
il était une période de leur vie où il y
avait même pas un commerce de proximité
ça ça veut dire revenir acheter une
pinte de lait si je manque de lait au
matin ces 120 km pour maple
les distances sont gagnent donc faut
subventionner en partie le transport
mais les gens qui nous écoutent 2 0 mais
il ya tellement peu de population
ça coûte tellement cher est ce qu'on va
injecter encore plus d'argent
le contenant on représente 1% de
l'ensemble du québec en population mais
notre bible il représente 2.2 pour ça
que tu es en inde une région de
ressources naturelles ont contribué à la
richesse du québec hydro-québec ses
revenus nets la part s'élevait à 5.3
millions bon simplement au québec
baden une fois plus pour vous contribuez
à corbeil un coût beaucoup plus à votre
richesse va à la nôtre